magic to quizzes and therapy so your
cubby so much added in and then do
believe me he saw his son saw me a large
out of ha ha shiny mentor and it isn't
reading process a sudden there was a
shatters and what Reggie Miller's we saw
like El Salado there is a place in
northern wage oh where a spiced reign
supreme
it's become known simply as China Chile
City
Mateos Adam Mayes Harrison Ave it's
awesome Mayawati hola darc shoulders
make each other powder Tanzania Rosario
Votolato Sabina Shahar Lockwood Salado
the town is home to the largest chili
market in China which produces countless
tons of chillies annually one worker can
manually process over 200 pounds of
chili every day
yo T peasant my agenda bar au chante yo
te hará hot on the market processes many
types of chilies but each is a flavor
profile unique to gray Joe instead of a
numbing level of spiciness found in
neighboring provinces the peppers from
Guangzhou are uniquely both sour and
spicy
tane mahuta generation formula Navajo
were Shanghai aparajita kaha Cantina
karate good sites for charitable sonoma
[Music]
the peppers are then shipped around the
world and the locals are fiercely proud
of their fiery export so the line of the
poor wealthy woman quit those three
shots at a large on Wonder nibs took a
larger said you saw the yellow down
[Music]
you